the Joe Rogan experience I wonder who
the first [ __ ] monkey was to figure
out our skin and animal and where its
skin you know had to be like in the
monkey days right now it feels like it'd
be a couple generations away from the
monkey maybes don't you think maybe it
was my cousin
I just can't imagine a monkey doing one
mean [ __ ] chimp and they were
going north and there's one dude who
always annoyed them so he kills him with
a rock and then uses the rock to take
his [ __ ] skin off and where is it to
freak everybody else out but then he
realizes it makes him warm you go a
little further north uh-huh that's like
a movie okay I like it a movie can you
see that scene I can see that that that
that's like that's what the entire movie
leads up to wonderful in the first
monkey figured out he could kill an
animal with like a tool like the firt
like Australia Pittacus or one of those
oh yeah primitive humans when the first
one was that stabbed something like a
stabbed a rat or a rabbit with a stick
and what holy [ __ ] right I can just use
this tool yeah what other tools I'm
gonna start eating yeah I'm gonna eat
good because if you didn't have a weapon
how hard is it for a person to kill
something with your hands what are you
even gonna get what are you gonna catch
what the [ __ ] can you catch with your
hands well can't catch a squirrel you'd
be just your hands no tools you'd be
hunting and gathering mostly I mean that
I mean gathering I would say yeah you'd
be eating [ __ ] that you found on the
ground yeah that's primarily what you
would eat and then once in a while you'd
get something an animal but but yeah but
then they had yeah you're right they
obviously had to figure out different
ways of getting animals well it's one of
the shifts that they think took place
that allowed the human brain size to
double over a period of two million
years no real human brain size
apparently I was listening to a Terence
Mckenna lecture on this once and he was
talking about all the human brain size
doubled over the period of two million
years it's one of the biggest mysteries
in the fossil record and his idea was
that they discovered mushrooms in that
the chimps over this period of time with
the monkey people whatever the [ __ ] they
were in ancient hominids yeah had
discovered mushrooms after the climate
had shifted and he
backs it up he did back at that place
he's dead now he backed it up with some
climate data that we know from you know
core samples and stuff like that yeah he
thinks that they experienced climate
change where the rainforests had receded
in the grasslands and that this gave
birth to the rise of ungulates like cows
and you know deer and things like that
yeah and they would [ __ ] these mushrooms
would grow on their [ __ ] and then
they've observed a lot of these monkeys
in the wild
picking up cow patties and looking for
grubs and beetles underneath it I think
they might have experimented with the
mushrooms and that if they experimented
with psilocybin mushrooms a lot of
things could take place once they
realized that it was not just a viable
food source but also provided them with
a bunch of different benefits one being
their vision and increases visual cue
they know we're seeing those roses yeah
so I'm gonna make them see things better
to makes them hornier makes it more
communal and it makes them more creative
and all those things possibly could have
given birth to the two to language and
to a lot of other things they also think
it's possible that that creativity could
have enabled them to start hunting that
they started using tools and you and
thinking and and and trying to figure
out ways around stuff and trying to you
know try to figure out how to make an
effective weapon to kill something in
the distance like the more they're
thinking and becoming creative the more
that stuff's enhancing them and this
this period of two million years is like
a pretty profound jump for the human
brain sighs they think some of that also
came to do with our desire to kill
things with with weapons but once we
started hunting and eating meat we got
way more protein more bioavailable
protein laws it was healthier for the
animal for the human animal and then we
also started to try to figure out other
better ways to kill these animals which
made it even more creative and
competitive yeah yeah and they think
that all this is all these factors might
have taken place that turned us into a
person that's pretty amazing
two million years yeah it's just like a
deviation well you know it's even
crazier 65 million years ago we were
like a mole oh yeah people were like a
little shrew that's our that's our
ancestor that's right
what's the name of that thing no man I
think it's sort of Norfolk or if good
trick
well it's Norfolk Oh Sir Francis is I
think you're right North Crispus
district it was like a weird little Mole
Christmas with this that's what it is
yeah it's some little little tiny rodent
yeah because I did a podcast or it with
oh there it is the alias of what is that
word you three in eutherian mammals was
a small rat-like creature depicted in
this illustration that lived 145 million
years ago in the shadow of the dinosaurs
so that rat-like creature apparently
survived the earthquake impact I don't
think that's the thing though it's
there's another there's a formal name
for it I would I know because I was on a
podcast and they were one of the
segments of it they talked about this
thing this is but they don't the only
reason why I'm skeptical because it says
145 million years ago but I guess maybe
they survived the impact scroll back up
to the top of the title says these
rodent-like creatures are the earliest
known ancestors of humans whales and
truth oh okay that's even more crazy
like we used to be a whale
yes our ancestor we shared a common
ancestor I should say yeah we like went
into the sea and then yeah on land that
thing that [ __ ] rat became a whale
what maybe that's it okay mm-hmm that
turned into a person folks think about
that we set in your rat traps and then
100 million years from now rats might be
some super superior human form I think
that's very possible but I mean that I
get why Christians are skeptical now
like what do you show me your work God
made this God didn't I was not a rat I
was not a rat sir
[Applause]